borders libertarian come on borders so i
talked to joe by borders okay
you know let people come in you know
don't worry about it we don't have to
worry about it what is your position
when it comes down to the borders oh
yeah so i have a very different uh
outlook on borders that and there's
there's a big divide there's been a big
split amongst libertarians i'm not an
open borders guy um i i don't believe
that that's the correct libertarian
position um my thing is that like in the
philosophical abstract i don't think
that anybody inherently has a right to
go some to an area that they don't own
or are not invited to and so i think
that probably my ideal situation under
the current paradigm would be something
like a sponsorship system an invitee
system where you basically have to get
an american citizen to vouch for you and
financially kind of you know like back
you in order to come into the country i
don't think that just robes of people
showing up have some inherent right to
be here because they decided they wanted
to um but the current system is bait is
is insane yes i mean we basically we
subsidize if the taxpayer is forced to
subsidize immigration and then the
taxpayer is forced to sub
subsidize the war on immigration and
then just everything about it is madness
so the number one thing is that you end
the war on drugs you roll back as much
of the warfare state the welfare state
as you can this way you're not
subsidizing people to come in and you
cut down on the black markets and the
smuggling and all of that stuff and all
of the the interventions in uh in latin
america and all of the the dea
operations there where we prop up the
cartels that makes life miserable for
people in those countries and leads to
more floods of of immigration i'd like
to take more steps like that but i am
not on the joe jorgensen idea of like
just
i think the idea that under current
situations just opening the borders
tomorrow did you not trust the idea of a
border
um i've always had the the kind of ron
paul um conspiratorial skepticism that i
don't like the idea of building walls i
think they could be used to keep us in
and um i like i i don't like walls
on kind of i think really bad
governments tend to build walls and i
don't like that uh but i do think that
it was reasonable that donald trump
stood up for tens of millions of
americans who were like look we do not
like that we have no say in who comes
into our country i think that's a
reasonable position for those people
it makes them evil racist for feeling
that way you can have vibrant
immigration and secular borders and this
is the policy what we should be doing
about it for literally six years you
build two ellis islands on a southern
border one may be in texas maybe one in
california these two ellis islands are
controlled by two separate companies and
the companies are private companies and
they're basically recruiting companies
if you want to come to our country you
go to on the ellis islands what you do
you go there and they put you in
quarantine or give you your check-ins
whatever they do they check you out if
you are okay they give you an orange
card in any state of degrees that that
once this this thing they send you off
to that state to go work we know that
you're working in that state you check
in every two years while you're there
you are not allowed to take any public
assistance at all and you pay your taxes
all you do you just check in if you
check if you don't check it in two years
we come get you we know where you are we
come get you if you do check in as long
as everything good keep going another
two years you keep going now how do you
pay for that we don't pay for that they
do there's a model that's already
working it's called recruiting companies
recruiters get paid as they place people
right now farms um people in the
hospitality industry restaurants
industries are spending billions of
dollars in the black market to get labor
well don't spend in the black market
just pay these guys they'll get you
workers as much as you want now what up
the people you say well women they're
still bad people yes they won't go to
the ellis islands they'll be along the
border that's what you use border patrol
for to get the bad guys this was the
only people starving the deserts aren't
innocent families they're bad guys who
are doing bad things i don't want anyone
to stop in the desert but if anyone's
going to stop in the desert let it be
them and our border patrol without
having to raise any extra money is now
focused only on that well larry what if
one of those those those those
islands do poorly or hurt people that's
why there's two of them people will go
to the one they want as they're making
money and the market will make it better
and better but it's a bigger piece of
that there's give or take 10 to 12
million people in america right now who
are undocumented we don't know what
they're doing where they are they can go
to the ellis island too they can pack up
and just go there and go you know what
i'm gonna get i want to become legal
great go to the house island spend your
30 days get checked out you're good go
back to work work legally when they go
back all of a sudden the rest of people
in the community go huh so you didn't
get deported no i did my paperwork i pay
my taxes i don't take i i don't take any
any um you know public assistance
they're gonna start going too which
makes law enforcement's job easier there
are bad people who come across the
border in our country we can't get them
they're all in enclaves right now and
everyone's scared to say where bad pablo
is but if all of a sudden they're legal
they can call the cops where's ben pablo
right there don't see him go get him
cops i'm not getting deported he can't
blackmail me anymore so now law
enforcement can do the job you will
watch the the undocumented population
shrink over the course of 10 years
because most would just go get
documented and the bad guys will get
caught this is an actual system that can
work and we can build more of them as
many as people want build a bunch of
them if people want to doesn't matter
but here's the best part if you do that
you now can make a private company
authorized to now give things like green
cards right say over 10 years or
whatever take a test or whatever
whatever rules you want they can start
doing that process through that whether
you speak english or whatever's the
rules you create those rules well that
doesn't affect anybody in line for the
government in fact eventually the
government will probably be worse people
start going to that instead of going
through the government we'll save money
because more people will go those ellis
islands then go through the government
system this is an actual libertarian
solution the market is stepped in we
don't raise any extra money nourish your
taxes everyone gets better service and
law enforcement is assisted and if you
couple that with what dave was saying
ending the main reasons for these
massive surges to begin with which is
the dea and the cia and other government
agencies through the war on drugs
sponsoring the us-sponsored cartels to
fight against the russia and
china-sponsored cartels so that they can
take over this country and massacre
anyone that didn't vote for their
candidates that's why they're fleeing
that's why you have i mean think of the
sophie's choice situation that so many
people there are making where they're
sending their children off with
smugglers they don't know knowing the
likelihood of them getting raped and
beginning sex trafficked them get ending
up in one of these uh cages i'm sorry
joe biden's president now these shelters
they're not okay they're not they stop
being cages january of 21. but they're
doing that because they know the
likelihood of them staying there is
almost 100 that they'll be killed that's
the kind of problems that are being
caused by the war on drugs when you end
that a lot of these surges aren't
happening and now whatever system we use
whether it's through sponsorship whether
it's through more of an ellis island
style system whatever it is you're not
going to be managing all of the people
that are coming here the current system
we have now the war on drugs and the war
on migration have led to both a bunch of
people who are just trying to flee
violence in cages
or being separated from their families
which by the way is
costing the taxpayer uh anywhere between
five and eight hundred dollars per day
per person many of them spend months in
there i mean you want to talk about a
welfare system that costs far more than
any welfare system right you've got that
going on you've got this this major
impediment to the flow of goods and
services and people across the borders
including to your point about uh
walls being used the other way
increasingly traffic into mexico is
being stopped by border patrol agents
for national security and drug control
reasons it's for control it's another
way to skim right but so
that's happening and in the midst of all
that there are still millions of people
here illegally including ms-13 members
and all the worst scary people and and
also a lot of people that aren't they
just there is no legal process for them
to come here so they came here illegally
if you focus on if if you allow people
to come and you have a more expedited
system
then now law enforcement can focus on
actual bad guys like larry and dave both
said and i can speak on this as someone
who uh my wife when we got married i was
her sponsor to come here the process we
went through that cost thousands of
dollars
did absolutely nothing had my wife been
a terrorist or whatever else nothing
they did
would have stopped her from coming in
they asked her are you a terrorist
no okay are you a communist
no are you they asked her if she was a
nazi my wife is black and i'm jewish
she told them that okay just you know
we're talking about good for you we're
talking about doing something what was
her answer
don't leave us i'm trying to create a
cliffhanger here okay listen i know how
to build up a story so they asked her if
she's a nazi she said i'm black my
husband is jewish do you know what the
response of the people who we have put
in charge or our government has put in
charge of protecting us well ma'am uh
your husband could be a nazi if you
wanted to he's an american citizen
these are the people when we're saying
we need to protect ourselves from the
bad guy this guy heard i'm black and my
husband's jewish and somehow that made
him think well i get why he could be a
nazi if he wanted to these are not we're
not sending our best okay when it comes
right not sending our best and brightest
this is another government program and
government programs don't do a good job
at fixing this we fix this by dealing
with the government interventions that
have made this worse and then whatever
is left we can deal with that through
market through sponsorships through a
private ellis island system whatever but
do it in a way that now it's not this
massive you know crisis surge you don't
have this humanitarian crisis on the
border you don't have children in cages
you don't have millions of people here
illegally including uh gang members and
everything else and if there's any shot
that they have of stopping bad guys from
getting in here it's going to be from
them focusing on the people who are the
most likely to be the bad guys because
coming here for the right reasons is
easy and able to be done
so you guys are on the same page on this
stop
more or less i mean like we have we have
slight differences probably between all
three of us but i do i do think that
really like right what we'd all probably
agree on is that right at the heart of
this is a war on drugs issue i mean the
major problem that you have at the
border is the the gang element of it the
criminal element of it the drugs that
are being smuggled in the crime that's
associated with that and much like you
know when when we tried uh prohibition
that all of a sudden it was like there
was this criminal gang mob element that
rose up with it now
after repealing prohibition the murder
rate dramatically fell the crime rate
dramatically fell now alcohol still is a
problem i mean alcohol isn't great and
there are people who abuse it there are
people who ruin their lives over it
there are people who are get very
violent when they're on it it's relate
like there's a bunch of problems with it
but you don't have the gang criminal
problem still associated with alcohol
because it's legalized and likewise that
would happen with these other drugs as
well that doesn't mean there's no
problems associated with it you know
like everything in life is trade-offs
there's costs and benefits to everything
it's just that the costs are far worse
of black markets and prohibition than
they are of legalism so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you